This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。在Look Back at It播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们挑选一年，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯为您带来的《学乖》。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全、无法进行的坦诚对话。但你可以和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲？这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就必须这样做。在AHA广播App、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听和学习《学乖》。2023年，“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
艾伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我只伪造了一次检测报告。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困之爱》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健康体魄以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》？也就是2%？
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Okay. So one of the big hot topics in psychology online, in the media, especially in self-help communities at the moment is attachment styles. Attachment theory essentially says that we learn how to form intimate attachments and bond with others based on our childhood experiences. And when those experiences and our primary relationship
大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能来到这里收听新的一集，当然，我们要在这一集中剖析20多岁的心理学。好的。那么，网络上、媒体中，尤其是在当下的自助社群中，心理学的一个热门话题就是依恋风格。依恋理论基本上认为，我们是如何学会形成亲密依恋并与他人建立联系的，这是基于我们的童年经历。而当这些经历以及我们与照顾者的主要关系
with our caregivers is disturbed or difficult, it can lead to a disorganized attachment style. Now, I think that it is so amazing that so many more of our own. us have the language to describe how we relate to others, how we form attachments. It is one of the biggest and most valuable important theories in psychology, with a small caveat being that I also think it's important that we get it right. And if we are going to apply these labels of insecure, of anxious, of avoidant, we actually know what it means. So today we are bringing back a favorite guest of ours, somebody who has been on the show before. And also one of the words, world's biggest experts on the topic of attachment styles and attachment theory.
受到干扰或变得困难时，它就会导致紊乱型依恋风格。现在，我认为非常棒的是，我们当中有更多的人拥有了词汇来描述我们如何与他人建立关系，如何形成依恋。这是心理学中最具价值和最重要的理论之一，其中一个小小的注意事项是，我也认为我们弄对这一点很重要。如果我们打算应用这些不安全型、焦虑型、回避型的标签，我们实际上需要知道它意味着什么。所以今天我们请回了一位我们最喜欢的嘉宾，她以前上过这个节目。同时也是世界上在依恋风格和依恋理论领域的顶尖专家之一。
Tais Gibson, welcome to the show. Thank you for having me. Excited to be back here with you. Yeah. So for those of you who don't know, we've previously done an episode on anxious attachment theory or anxious attachment style, sorry, last year, which actually goes into the overall theory a little bit more around, you know, John Bolby, Mary Ainsworth, who created this theory and like the unique style. So if you miss that, I would recommend going back and listening
泰斯·吉布森，欢迎来到节目。谢谢邀请我。很高兴能再次来到这里与你交流。好的。所以对于那些不知道的人，我们去年曾经做过一期关于焦虑型依恋理论或焦虑型依恋风格的节目，抱歉，那期节目其实更多地探讨了整体理论，比如约翰·鲍比、玛丽·爱因斯坦——创造了这个理论的人——以及这种独特的风格。如果你错过了那一期，我建议你回去听听
to that episode. But can you tell us a little bit about yourself and yeah, I guess where your interest in attachment theory really began? Yeah. So I really started getting interested in people, I think, at a really young age. So I went through a family dynamic that was pretty chaotic. There was a lot of intense fighting and arguments and saw my parents go through like a very long, and quite intense divorce that went all the way to like the superior court of Canada, like all these sort of dramatic things. And I think I was a really sensitive kid and I was parentified a lot. So what that really means for anybody who's not familiar with that term is I was put in the middle
那一集。但你能否跟我们简短介绍一下你自己，还有，我想知道你对依恋理论的兴趣究竟是从哪里开始的？好的。所以我对人真正产生兴趣，我想，是从很小的时候开始的。我经历了一个相当混乱的家庭动态。有很多激烈的争吵和辩论，我看着父母经历了一场非常漫长且相当激烈的离婚，甚至打到了加拿大最高法院这样的最高审级，发生了所有这些充满戏剧性的事情。我想我是一个非常敏感的孩子，我承担了很多过度成人化的角色。所以对于任何不熟悉这个术语的人来说，这意味着我在很小的时候就被置于中间，
at a very young age, sort of forced to play like an emotional parent role for my parents. And they would both vent to me about each other a lot. And I think I spent a lot of my early childhood wondering like, why do things have to be so difficult. Why can't people who love each other just kind of come together and figure it out? And like, you know, they obviously care about each other and they care about me and my sister. But why can't they just figure out how to not be like this with one another? Because they really kind of brought out those hard parts of each other. So from a really young age, I was really interested in like people and human dynamics. And I was definitely there
被迫为我的父母扮演类似于情感父母的角色。他们俩会经常向我倾诉对彼此的不满。我想我的童年早期花了很多时间在想，为什么事情非得这么难呢？为什么相爱的人就不能聚在一起把问题解决好呢？就像，你知道，他们显然在乎彼此，也在乎我和我姐姐。但为什么他们就是搞不懂如何能不以这种方式对待彼此呢？因为他们确实把彼此身上那些坚硬的部分都激发出来了。所以从很小的时候起，我就对人和人类动力学非常感兴趣。而且我绝对也是
as sort of the therapist kind of child for my parents too. So I think it was just very natural for me to evolve into this type of work. It was definitely not something I disliked. I always liked talking about real things and breaking things down. And it was through my own kind of struggles as like a teenager and going into my early adult years that I ended up doing a much deeper dive
充当了父母的心理治疗师类型的小孩。所以我觉得自己很自然地就步入了这种类型的工作。这绝对不是我不喜欢的事情。我一直喜欢谈论真实的事情，喜欢剖析问题。正是通过我作为青少年以及步入成年早期时自身的种种挣扎，我最终进行了更深入的探讨，
in a more serious way until like how do we really heal? How do we really work through these things? And it was through that that one of the things I revisited was attachment styles. And ended up sort of combining a lot of my research and hypnosis with my background and a lot in like the subconscious mind and then traditional psychology and the traditional sort of school system route I combined that with the the principles of CBT and NLP and ultimately attachment styles to really create a body of work about how not only can we
以一种更严肃的方式研究：我们究竟该如何疗愈？我们究竟该如何克服这些问题？正是在这个过程中，我重新审视的事情之一就是依恋风格。并最终将我的许多研究和催眠，与我的背景——很大程度上涉及潜意识——以及传统心理学和传统的学校教育路线结合起来，将其与CBT和NLP的原则以及最终的依恋风格相结合，真正创造了一套关于我们不仅如何能够
change our attachment style and become securely attached but also diving deeper into the work of John Bolby and Mary Ainsworth of how our attachment style originally forms so basically went on to run like a 10 year almost 10 year client practice and then put a whole bunch of programs online with the personal developments, well, all about the attachment theory kind of stuff. Oh my gosh. I love that whole story because I feel like you make a great point, which is that yes, the original theory is like amazing and it's such a solid foundation, but our understanding of how the human mind works has also evolved a little bit. And so it's important to kind of evolve our traditional and conventional theories with like that more modern
改变我们的依恋风格并变得安全型依恋，而且深入探讨约翰·鲍比和玛丽·爱因斯坦关于我们的依恋风格最初是如何形成的工作的作品。所以基本上我接着经营了一家差不多10年的客户咨询诊所，然后把一大堆关于个人发展的项目放到网上，都是关于依恋理论之类的内容。天哪。我非常喜欢这个完整的故事，因为我觉得你提出了一个很好的观点，那就是：没错，最初的理论非常棒，而且它是一个如此坚实的基础，但我们对人脑工作原理的理解也已经有了一点演变。所以，把我们的传统和常规理论与这种更现代的理解结合起来演变，是很重要的。
understanding. You also spoke about parentification, which I find to be such a fascinating subject. For those of us who don't know what that means, it's basically you become the parent for your parents. So that child parent dynamic actually kind of reverses. And so you might
你还谈到了过度成人化（parentification），我发现这是一个非常迷人的主题。对于我们这些不知道这意味着什么的人来说，这基本上就是你变成了你父母的家长。所以那个儿童-父母的动态实际上反过来了。因此你可能会
become a confident, you might be a mediator, like you said, you might have to provide for them physically, emotionally, financially, what do you think, is there like a specific attachment style that that normally contributes to? Because part of me is like, oh, is it, would it be secure because your parent really needed you or would it be avoided? Such a good question. It's so interesting. So a lot of the research and attachment styles actually shows that you're more likely to become at least a fearful avoidant or a dismissible avoidant. Like have an avoidant side, the more enmeshed you are
成为一个自信的人，你可能会成为一个调解员，就像你说的，你可能不得不为他们在物质上、情感上、经济上提供支持。你认为，这通常与哪种特定的依恋风格有关？因为我心里的一部分会想，哦，是因为你的父母真的很需要你，所以它是安全型的吗？还是回避型的？这是一个很好的问题。太有趣了。因此，关于依恋风格的大量研究实际上表明，你越是在年轻时与父母过度纠缠（enmeshed），你就越有可能成为至少恐惧回避型或疏离回避型。也就是说，你有回避的一面。
at a young age with your parents. And I think part of what often happens is that you'll have that side of like feeling engulfed and overwhelmed. And obviously in like traditional dismissive avoidant, the two fears are really about engulfment and then being defective in some way, right? So if you're being trapped in the wrong relationship or and a lot of that trapped core fear first comes from being enmeshed in some form, whether it was through parentification or just, I talk a lot about this topic.
而且我想经常发生的情况的一部分是，你会产生那种感到被吞没和被压倒的一面。显然，在传统的疏离回避型中，这两个恐惧实际上是关于被吞没，然后是以某种方式存在缺陷，对吧？所以如果你被困在错误的关系中，或者那种被困的核心恐惧很大一部分首先来自于某种形式的纠缠，无论是通过过度成人化，还是仅仅——我经常谈论这个话题。
it's interesting. We have like direct parentification and indirect parentification. So direct is like myself and I was a fearful avoidant before working on my attachment style. And my direct was like I was directly in the middle. People directly coming to me in client practice and through our programs at PDS. I've often seen instead that dismissible wins are indirectly parentified. So they may have a parent who's like very depressed all the time and the other parent not around. And they start worrying like, okay, my parents not okay, and if they're not okay, how will I be okay, right? Because we're, we're very aware that we're completely dependent on our caregivers for survival at a young age. And so if there's a combination of avoidance and an indirect enmeshment, I find that to be
这很有趣。我们有直接的过度成人化和间接的过度成人化。所以直接的就像是我自己，我在致力于改变依恋风格之前曾经是一个恐惧回避型。我的直接表现就是我直接处于中间。人们直接来找我做咨询，并通过我们在PDS的项目。我经常看到的情况是，疏离回避型反而是间接过度成人化的。所以他们可能会有一个总是非常沮丧的父母，而另一个父母不在身边。然后他们开始担心，好吧，我的父母不好，如果他们不好，我怎么能好呢？对吧？因为我们非常清楚，在年幼时我们完全依赖照顾者生存。所以如果回避和间接纠缠结合在一起，我发现这是最稳定的产出，会造就一个成年的疏离回避型。
the most consistent output that will produce a dismissive avoidance as an adult. That makes so much sense, like the engulfment, the enmeshment. I feel like we've jumped the gun. I've jumped the gun. I went straight to like an in-depth question about avoiding attachment style but that's what we're focusing on today what exactly makes somebody avoidant how common is this in society can you kind of break down something you've already spoken about is dismissive versus fearful can you break down what it means to be somebody who is avoidantly attached according to theory according to your own personal experiences as well yes it's such a good question so there's two quote unquote avoidant attachment styles one is fearful avoidant and one is
这太有道理了，比如被吞没感，纠缠感。我觉得我们有点操之过急了。我操之过急了。我直接跳到了关于回避型依恋风格的深度问题，但这正是我们今天关注的重点：究竟是什么让一个人变得回避？这在社会上有多普遍？你能否剖析一下你刚才已经说过的内容，即疏离型与恐惧型的区别？根据理论以及你个人的亲身经历，你能否剖析一下成为一个回避型依恋的人意味着什么？是的，这是一个很好的问题。所以有两个所谓的“回避型”依恋风格，一个是恐惧回避型，一个是
dismissive avoidant. So fearful avoidance, one of the big differentiators, is they have an anxious side. So they basically oscillate between being anxious and avoidant. And they basically, because they grow up with conflicting ideas about love, they often have some very good experiences with love, like having some very loving moments, some caring moments, and then having some really chaotic ones. And fearful avoidance are characterized by a little bit more trauma than the average attachment style. That's the type of trauma we think like big T trauma. So it can be physical abuse, emotional abuse, sexual abuse, addiction in the family or household, really, really intense divorce processes, these kinds of things where there's a lot of that intensity. And dismissive avoidance are characterized
疏离回避型。所以恐惧回避型，其中一个很大的区别是，他们有焦虑的一面。所以他们基本上在焦虑和回避之间摇摆。而且他们基本上，因为他们带着关于爱的冲突观念长大，他们经常有一些非常美好的爱的体验，比如有一些非常充满爱意的时刻，一些关怀的时刻，然后又经历一些非常混乱的时刻。恐惧回避型的特征是比平均依恋风格带有更多的创伤。这就是我们所认为的大T创伤。所以它可以是身体虐待、情感虐待、性虐待、家庭或家里的成瘾问题、非常非常激烈的离婚过程，诸如此类有很多这种强烈情绪的事情。而疏离回避型的特征
more by emotional neglect, but also can be combined with that sense of engulfment or enmeshment. So fearful avoidance will tend to have that side of like fearing abandonment and yearning for closeness, but then also fearing engulfment and enmeshment and entrapment in their relationships. and so they can really go from being really hot to very cold. So they're kind of the attachment style. If anybody's newer to this stuff, it's like, come get close to me, come get close. I want love. And then they're like, no, get back.
更多的是情感忽视，但也可能伴随着那种被吞没或纠缠的感觉。所以恐惧回避型往往会有那种害怕被抛弃、渴望亲密，但同时也害怕在关系中被吞没、纠缠和陷入其中的一面。所以他们真的可以从非常热情变得非常冷淡。所以他们就是那种依恋风格。如果任何人对这些内容还比较陌生，那就是：过来靠近我，过来靠近。我想要爱。然后他们又说：不，退后。
You're too close. And I experienced that my whole early teenage years and early adult life. Like I would constantly be like, I really want connection. I really care about connection. And then when I felt really connected or attached to people, it would terrify me. I would be like, we're going to hurt me. Something bad's going to happen. And I would try to start pushing them away.
你太近了。我在整个青少年早期和成年早期都经历过这种感觉。我总是会说：我真的很想要连接。我真的很在乎连接。然后当我真正感到与人连接或依恋时，我会感到恐惧。我会想：我们会伤害我的。会有不好的事情发生。然后我会试图把他们推开。
And I was less like that with friendship. but I was extremely like that with romantic relationships. I was probably a very difficult person to be with before doing the work. And so, you know, it's because we first have those core fears about like closeness has good moments, but it also has really scary moments. And so we go back and forth within ourselves, which really mirrors back the way we were conditioned about love and attachments begin with. And then dismissible avoidance, their overarching theme is childhood emotional neglect.
我在友情方面没那么严重，但我在恋爱关系中极其严重。在做个人成长之前，我可能是一个非常难相处的人。所以，你知道，这是因为我们首先对亲密关系有着核心恐惧，即亲密有美好的时刻，但也有非常可怕的时刻。所以我们在内心深处来回拉扯，这真实地反映了我们最初被塑造的关于爱和依恋的条件反射。然后是疏离回避型，他们的总体主题是童年情感忽视。
So, you know, generally we'll see that they neglect their own emotions as adults because there was never really a lot of emotional attunement. And if that's combined with indirect and meshment and the fear of getting too close or being engulfed, you'll see that they tend to be people who constantly keep people at arm's length. And so they may show up in like the dating stage of relationships when their first, the attachment bond hasn't been built yet. And they may be more charming or charismatic or seem to be, you know, quite available in a lot of different ways then. But once they start to attach, they tend to just exclusively fear being trapped or being criticized. And so they'll really push back and they may be the type of attachment style that, you know, seems unable to commit, pushes away all of a sudden out of the blue, even when commitment's just starting and when things are getting more real.
所以，你知道，通常我们会发现他们在成年后会忽视自己的情绪，因为从来没有过太多的情感调谐。如果这与间接纠缠以及对靠得太近或被吞没的恐惧相结合，你会发现他们往往是那些总是与人保持距离的人。所以他们可能会在关系的约会阶段表现出来，当他们第一次、依恋纽带尚未建立时。那时他们可能更有魅力、更有个人吸引力，或者在很多不同的方面看起来（情感上）相当可及。但一旦他们开始依恋，他们往往就会极度害怕被困住或被批评。所以他们会强烈抗拒，他们可能是那种似乎无法承诺、毫无征兆地突然把人推开的依恋风格，即使是在承诺刚开始、事情变得越来越真实的时候。
And they'll work really hard to maintain their privacy and their distance from people a lot of the time because as a child's closeness meant I was neglected and I was engulfed. And so those are things that they're scared to relive as adults and they'll go out of their way to stop that from happening. So those are sort of the two avoid and attachment cells and some of those key differences between them. That was like so succinct. I also like the point that you made around it being kind of a self-fulfilling prophecy, right? Like you start pushing away so they start behaving the way that you always expected people you are close to to behave. And so you reinforce that like primary maladaptive behavior of once again avoiding connection and perhaps self-sabotaging. Okay, I have a hot seat question.
而且很多时候，他们会非常努力地维护自己的隐私和与他人的距离，因为对一个孩子来说，亲密意味着我被忽视了，我被吞没了。所以这些是他们害怕在成年后重温的事情，他们会不遗余力地阻止这种情况发生。所以这些就是这两种回避型依恋风格以及它们之间的一些关键区别。这真是太精辟了。我也很喜欢你提出的关于这是一种自证预言的观点，对吧？就像你开始把别人推开，于是他们开始表现出你一直期望的那些与你亲近的人会表现出的行为。于是你强化了那种再次回避连接、也许是自我破坏的主要适应不良行为。好的，我有一个火热的问题要问你。
for you and maybe you probably do know the answer to this but how common is avoid an attachment in society really good question so there hasn't been a huge body of recent research done about the attachment breakdown about 30 years ago research showed that it was roughly 50% of people are secure and then research showed that somewhere between 5% and 10% of people were disorganized attachment style and then the rest of the split was between anxious and dismissive avoidant. And disorganized is also, sorry, fearful avoidant, aka disorganized attachment style. They're often referred to as the same thing. It's the same attachment style at the end of the day.
也许你大概知道答案，但在社会中，回避型依恋到底有多普遍？这是一个非常好的问题。所以，关于依恋细分情况并没有进行过大量近期的研究。大约30年前的研究显示，大约50%的人是安全型的，然后研究显示大约5%到10%的人是紊乱型依恋风格，其余的比例则在焦虑型和疏离回避型之间分配。紊乱型也是，抱歉，恐惧回避型，也就是紊乱型依恋风格。人们经常把它们称为同一个东西。归根结底，它们是同一种依恋风格。
So it's funny because, you know, we have a big attachment style quiz. We have a lot of people to come in, take it, and tons of people will be like, I tested this way, but I realized through doing some of the coursework, I'm actually this attachment style. It's one of the most common things we see. And research shows very conclusively, historically, that self-reporting is not always the most accurate thing. Sometimes, you know, although research will show that, you know, we're looking at the totality of avoidant attachment, being somewhere around 20 to 30% shared by dismissal avoidant and fearful avoidant attachment style, I wouldn't be surprised if it's a little bit higher, particularly dismissive avoidance, because dismissible avoidance tend to self-report is more secure. I've absolutely noticed that pattern. And we've had like a couple million people take our attachment style quiz.
所以这很有趣，因为，你知道，我们有一个大型的依恋风格测试。我们有很多来访者参加测试，成千上万的人会说：我是这样测试出来的，但我通过做一些课程作业意识到，我实际上是这种依恋风格。这是我们看到的最常见的事情之一。而研究非常明确地历史性地表明，自我报告并不总是最准确的。有时，你知道，尽管研究会显示，我们着眼于回避型依恋的整体情况，由疏离回避型和恐惧回避型依恋风格共同占到大约20%到30%，但如果这个比例更高一些，我一点也不会感到惊讶，尤其是疏离回避型，因为疏离回避型倾向于将自己报告为更加安全型。我绝对注意到了这种模式。我们有大约几百万人在我们的依恋风格测试中进行了测试。
So it's not a small sample size. And what will happen is people will think that because, you know, they're repressing their emotions, which is very dismissive avoidant, and because they tend to not get into lots of fights or chaos in their relationships, they'll often conflate that with being securely attached, rather than realizing that what's securely attached actually means is we can work through our conflicts. We can express our emotions vulnerably. We can let people in and let our guard down and let somebody get to know us and we can invest in commitment and invest in a relationship. And those are really the cornerstones of what it means to be securely attached rather than the absence of arguing means secure attachment, which is what the DA tends to conflate things as. So I think that probably that percentage is significantly higher than just the 20 to 30%.
所以这不是一个小样本。会出现的情况是，人们会认为，因为，你知道，他们在压抑自己的情绪，这非常符合疏离回避型的特征，而且因为他们在关系中往往不会陷入大量的争吵或混乱，他们经常会把这与“安全型依恋”混为一谈，却没有意识到“安全型依恋”真正意味着：我们可以解决我们的冲突；我们可以毫无保留地表达我们的情绪；我们可以让别人走进来，放下防备，让别人了解我们，并且我们可以投入承诺，投入到一段关系中。这些才是成为安全型依恋的核心基石，而不是“没有争吵就意味着安全型依恋”，而这正是疏离回避型倾向于混淆的概念。所以我认为这个比例可能远远高于20%到30%。
but the more common research now that's coming out is at least showing that secure attachment style is on the decline over the last 30 years as well. I don't want to make, I'm going to make broad statements here and maybe they're not true and there probably should be more research into it. But I do feel like there is obviously a separation between parents and children more now, like with social media, with our phones that really stops children in a way of reaching out. but then also like parents from engaging properly with their children. And we also know that there is a lot of generational trauma that if not broken gets passed on. That's largely like there is like a core moment where you can kind of fix that, right? And it's like if people aren't doing the work, then it's not going to happen. That, you know, that's what happens.
但现在正在涌现的更普遍的研究至少表明，在过去30年里，安全型依恋风格也在呈下降趋势。我不想在这里发表过于宽泛的陈述，也许它们并不是真的，而且可能应该对此进行更多的研究。但我确实觉得，现在父母和孩子之间明显存在更多的隔阂，比如通过社交媒体、通过我们的手机，这实际上在某种程度上阻止了孩子们向外寻求连接。但同时也阻止了父母与孩子进行恰当的互动。而且我们也知道，有很多代际创伤，如果不去打破，就会传递下去。在很大程度上，这是一个核心时刻，你可以借此修复它，对吧？问题在于，如果人们不去做这些工作，那么它就不会发生。你知道，这就是会发生的情况。
I feel like, I don't know if that's a big broad statement, but we'll have to say. I thought that was a perfect statement. Like I really, really agree with that. I think that we're in a generation now or because of social media and the phone and convenience and also because of like a lot of our culture and a lot of places throughout the world is like hustle culture, like work so hard, do all these things. And obviously like just some of the things that are happening in the world too, like inflation and financial pressures, it's causing, you know, both parents to often be working and both parents
我觉得，我不知道这是一个不是过于宽泛的陈述，但我们拭目以待。我认为这是一个完美的陈述。我真的、真的非常赞同这一点。我认为我们现在正处于这样一代人中，因为社交媒体、手机和便利性，也因为我们的许多文化以及世界各地的许多地方都是“奋斗文化”——努力工作，做所有这些事情。显然，还有世界上正在发生的一些事情，比如通货膨胀和经济压力，这导致（你知道）父母双方往往都需要工作，父母双方
sometimes be working multiple jobs or to be overwhelmed and stressed. And just like you said, there's that generational trauma where if somebody's not right within themselves. I always say this. Like trauma is literally contagious. It's not contagious in like a germ theory way, the way we think of like contagion, but trauma is contagious. The more proximity you have to somebody who has unresolved trauma,
有时甚至要兼职多份工作，或者感到不知所措和压力山大。正如你所说，存在着那种代际创伤，如果一个人在内心没有调整好自己。我总是这么说。创伤实际上是会传染的。它不是那种像细菌理论那样我们认为的传染方式，但创伤确实会传染。你与有未解决创伤的人的接触越密切，
the greater likelihood that trauma is going to be passed along, right? And so to your point, if we have this fractured culture and this fractured sort of system that we're living in in a multitude of ways, of course that's going to affect somebody's attachment style. And so much of what really creates secure attachment is, is a caregiver able to be present? Are they able to exercise something called approach-oriented behaviors in psychology? Meaning that when a child cries or they seem distressed, the caregiver goes towards that child
这种创伤被传递下去的可能性就越大，对吧？所以按照你的观点，如果我们生活在一个以多种方式破碎的文化和破碎的体制中，这当然会影响到一个人的依恋风格。创造安全型依恋的很大一部分原因在于：照顾者能够保持在场吗？他们能够在心理学中练习一种叫做“趋向型行为”（approach-oriented behaviors）的东西吗？这意味着当一个孩子哭泣或看起来痛苦时，照顾者会走向那个孩子，
approaches them and tries to sue them, check in with their needs. And what that does is it allows a child to think like, okay, I'm worthy of expressing emotion. I'm worthy of, you know, negotiating my needs and conveying what they are. and I get positively reinforced by my parent when that happens. And in a culture where everybody's on their phones or everybody's over-stressed or overwhelmed or burnt out, and parents don't have that emotional availability in that same way, and they don't have as much bandwidth for those approach-oriented behaviors, of course that's going to affect the attachment style of children.
接近他们并试图安抚他们，关注他们的需求。这样做能让孩子觉得：好吧，我值得表达情绪。我值得去协商我的需求并传达它们。而且当我这样做时，我会得到父母的积极强化。在一个每个人都在玩手机、或者每个人都过度压力、过度疲惫或精疲力竭的文化中，父母没有那种同样的情感可及性，他们对那些趋向型行为也没有那么多的精力（bandwidth），这当然会影响到孩子的依恋风格。
So I really like that point as well. I feel like that is such a compelling thing because I see it a lot of the time. And it's not to say that people aren't trying the hardest and don't want to raise like amazing, beautiful, well-rounded children. It's just hard to do that when your environment is trying to keep you like overly stimulated by your phone or overly engaged in social media or in work or in anything like that. So this is kind of a follow-up question. Do you think people who are having a dismissive or a fearful attachment style? Do you think that they are aware as conscious of it. I think you kind of already mentioned this, right? They're less conscious of the fact that
所以我真的很喜欢这个观点。我觉得这是一个非常引人注目的事情，因为我经常看到这种情况。这并不是说人们没有尽最大努力，也不想抚养出惊艳、美丽、全面发展的孩子。只是当你的环境试图让你被手机过度刺激、或者过度沉迷于社交媒体、工作或任何诸如此类的事情中时，要做到这一点真的很困难。所以这是一个后续问题。你认为那些拥有疏离型或恐惧型依恋风格的人，他们对此有意识吗？我想你刚才已经提到了这一点，对吧？他们对以下事实的意识较少：
they have this attachment style. Is it because it's kind of like protective? Is there like, do you think that it's because that they implicitly have recognized a benefit in being this way so subconsciously like choose to be unaware of it? Why do you think people more so self-report is secure? This is such a good question. So I think the first two things is like the fearful wooden and dismissible are different. So fearful avoidance, like I was fearful of wouldn't, trust me, we know we're insecurely attached. Like it is loud and clear. Like, you'll be on the constant forever roller coaster of relationships until you heal your attachment style. So like, fearful avoidance, they always know. They're like the first to know like something is not right with my attachment
他们拥有这种依恋风格。这是因为它是一种保护机制吗？你认为这是因为他们含蓄地认识到了以这种方式存在的好处，所以下意识地选择对此浑然不知吗？为什么你认为人们更多地将自己报告为安全型？这是一个非常好的问题。所以我觉得前两点是，恐惧回避型和疏离回避型是不同的。比如恐惧回避型，就像我曾经是个恐惧回避型一样，相信我，我们知道我们是不安全型依恋。它是那么响亮而清晰。就像，你将永远处于关系的过山车中，直到你治愈你的依恋风格。所以像恐惧回避型，他们总是知道。他们是最先知道“我的依恋风格有些不对劲”的人，
cell because they have extreme highs and lows, like really good moments and then really, really awful or chaotic moments and trust issues and you name it. So fearful avoidance tend to know the most. But again, that's not like five to 10 percent segment of the population. The dismissible avoidance, which are sort of larger portion there, you'll generally see that I think you kind of nailed it. You hit the nail in the head there where they see an implicit benefit. First of all, if I grow up and I can't get my needs met, let's pretend I'm a dismissive avoidant for a moment, and I'm a child and I grow up and I can't get my needs met in a relationship from my parents, and I'm wired for biologically wired for attunement.
因为他们经历着极端的高潮和低谷，比如非常美好的时刻，然后是非常糟糕或混乱的时刻，还有信任问题，诸如此类。所以恐惧回避型往往是最清楚的。但再次强调，那并不是人口中5%到10%的那一部分。而疏离回避型，占了其中较大的一部分，你通常会看到——我想你确实说到点子上了。你一下子切中了要害，他们看到了潜在的好处。首先，如果我长大了，却无法在关系中从父母那里满足我的需求——假设我暂时是一个疏离回避型，我是一个孩子，我长大后无法在关系中从父母那里得到我的需求，而我是为了调谐而生物学上注定要连接的。
And my parents are emotionally unavailable. then what happens is I go, well, it doesn't feel good to keep yearning for something and get rejected. So I'm going to adapt to this by just repressing my need to even attach to them. And by doing that, it creates relief. And so now I think that keeping attachment in a distance is a very good thing. It gives me this reward feeling instead of, it gives me the relief instead of feeling like, oh, I'm just yearning for something and keep feeling rejected. And on top of that, dismissible avoidance, because they're suppressing their emotions, are less likely to feel their emotions and feel that something is off. And the third layer to that is that
而我的父母在情感上是不可及的。那么接下来发生的事情是，我会想：好吧，一直渴望某些东西却不断被拒绝感觉并不好。所以我将通过压抑自己与他们连接的需求来适应这一点。通过这样做，它带来了宽慰。所以现在我认为，与依恋保持距离是一件非常好的事情。它给了我这种获得奖赏的感觉，而不是——它给了我解脱感，而不是让我觉得：哦，我只是在渴望某些东西，却不断感到被拒绝。最重要的是，疏离回避型因为在压抑自己的情绪，所以更不容易去感受自己的情绪并感觉到有些不对劲。而这其中的第三层原因是，
dismissible avoidance end up in a dynamic where they go, well, I'm the logical one. I'm straightforward. I use my brain and I'm not really giving into my emotions. And of course, there's tremendous benefits to that, right? Like there can be huge benefits of all attachment styles that are insecurely attached. They have unique and really beautiful characteristics. But that's still going to be something that doesn't benefit relationships because when the moment comes to be raw and real and vulnerable and build a genuine connection, if somebody's so closed off to that, they can't even access that properly and they're terrified of it. And that becomes a really painful thing. So I think to your point, they are already suppressing their emotions so they don't even feel as much as something's off.
疏离回避型最终陷入了一种动态，他们会想：好吧，我是理性的那一个。我是直截了当的。我用我的大脑，我并没有真正沉溺于我的情绪。当然，这有巨大的好处，对吧？所有不安全型依恋风格都可能带来巨大的好处。他们有独特且非常美丽的特征。但这仍然对关系没有好处，因为当需要真诚、真实、脆弱并建立真正的连接的时刻到来时，如果一个人对这种事情如此抗拒，以至于他们甚至无法正常接触它，并且对此感到恐惧，那就变成了一件非常痛苦的事情。所以正如你所说，他们已经在压抑自己的情绪了，所以他们甚至不会觉得有什么不对劲。
And then they see a benefit in themselves being that way, which makes it kind of this catch-22 where it's even trickier to realize that something's not right. I'm going to ask a follow-up question here which is do you think that men or women are more likely to be this way because I get this question all the time where it's like the profile that you're you're describing right being incredibly rational right like that's something that I think we often associate with men that they are like these rational people when it comes to relationships and women are emotional whether that is correct or not or um this idea of like men are allowed to be a lot more emotionally closed off. Also the factor of like parentification, right? Like women are perhaps more
然后他们在自己身上看到了这种状态的好处，这就形成了一种进退维谷的局面，使得他们更难意识到有些事情不对劲。我要在这里问一个后续问题，那就是：你觉得男性还是女性更有可能呈现出这种状态？因为我经常被问到这个问题，比如你一直在描述的这种画像——非常理性，对吧？——这正是我们通常与男性联系在一起的东西，即他们在处理关系时是这样理性的人，而女性则是情绪化的，无论这种说法是否正确；或者还有这种观点，即男性被允许在情感上更加封闭。还有过度成人化的因素，对吧？女性也许承受了更多的过度成人化。这是否促成了她们的这种情况？这里有太多的问题，让我觉得这就像是一个天平，究竟有哪些语境、外部和环境因素在平衡这个天平，从而使得男性或女性更有可能表现出这种状态？这是一个非常棒的问题。所以有趣的是，在不同的文化中，你实际上会看到依恋风格的分布略有不同。所以这很有趣。在日本曾做过一项研究，结果表明许多个体更多地呈现出疏离回避型，而在文化上，表现得过于情绪化或过于脆弱会受到负面的强化，对吧？所以你可以看到其中一些动态。但正如你所说，绝对地，男性更有可能是疏离回避型，
parentified. So does that contribute to them? Like there's so many questions where I'm like, it's kind of like a scale to me of like which what like contextual and external and environmental factors are kind of balancing the scale to maybe make men or women more likely to present this way. It's such a great question. So it's interesting in different cultures, you'll actually see different attachment style spreads ever so slightly. So like it's interesting. There's a study done in Japan and it showed that a lot of individuals are more dismissive avoidant and culturally it's like negatively reinforced to be too emotional or too vulnerable right so you can see some of those dynamics but to your point absolutely men are more likely to be dismissive
而女性实际上更有可能是焦虑型依恋风格。目前的这种分布比例，虽然对此有相互竞争的研究，但看起来大约在80比20，或者75比25、25到75之间（男性与女性），就谁的比例上属于疏离回避型依恋风格而言。所以这非常合乎情理，对吧？男性通常承受更多关于情感的羞耻。他们通常被教导：不要像个爱哭鬼。长大点。
avoidance and women are actually more likely to be anxious attachment style this spread right now looks like there's competing studies on this stuff but it looks like it's somewhere between either 80 20 or 75 25 25 men to women in terms of who proportionally is dismissive avoidant attachment style. And so it makes a lot of sense, right? Men are generally more emotionally shamed. And they're generally taught like, don't be a cry baby. Grow up.
不要那么脆弱。别让任何人看到你哭。很多这样的信息，或者说信息变成了我们的条件反射。因此，许多这样的信息是在对一个人进行条件反射式的训练，让他们觉得：哦，我不能展示我自己的这些方面。我会遭到拒绝。如果我展示了我这一面的话，我会感到羞耻。
Don't be so vulnerable. Don't let anyone see you cry. Like a lot of that messaging, or messaging becomes our conditioning. And so a lot of that messaging is conditioning somebody to be like, oh, I can't show these sides of myself. I'll get rejected. I'll be, you know, shameful if I show the side of myself.
所以这为某人压抑自我中那些方面提供了更多的动力，而女性呢，（尽管这种情况最近有所改变），但女性往往仍然自然而然地（表现出），你知道，她们有这样一种文化：好吧，我们可以更多地表达我们的情绪，或者分享事情，或者比我们在男性群体中通常看到的更加开放和脆弱。是的，这就像是经典的社会学习理论，对吧？你观察你的父母如何表现，你周围的人如何表现，然后你复制并模仿它。如果你在一个社区、一种文化、一个环境中长大（我在澳大利亚，对吧？），成为一个非常“大男子主义”的男人、非常强硬、男人不哭、男人去球场上做所有的工作，这是一个巨大的社会要求。如果这就是你养成的环境，即使你知道这是不对的，即使你的父母知道这是不对的，并且非常努力地不去在你身上强行施加这一点，如果它就像是空气中的某种东西，如果它是你呼吸的东西，如果你去学校、去朋友家串门、去杂货店、打开电视时看到的就是它，它依然会以某种方式渗入进来并得到强化或奖励。你认为疏离型和恐惧型依恋风格分别对于不同的性别来说，看起来会有什么不同吗？
And so it gives even more incentive for somebody to repress those aspects of self, whereas women, you know, although this is changing more so recently a little bit, but women still tend to naturally be, you know, they have this culture where it's like, okay, we can express our emotions more or share things or be more open and vulnerable with each other than we would generally see in a group of men. Yeah, it's like classic social learning theory, right? Like you observe how your parents behave, how those around you behave and you replicate and you mimic it. And if you're growing up in a community, in a culture, in an environment, you know, I'm in Australia, right? Like, that's a huge thing to be like a very macho man and to be
这是一个非常好的问题。所以我想如果我们把每一种都拆解开来，作为男性和女性的疏离回避型，他们都往往分享一些独特的特征，但男性的疏离回避型在社会上通常会更被接受一些，类似于我们在这个概念上谈论的内容。所以我觉得值得注意的是，你的主要最初影响将在家里，因为基本上我们如何从神经可塑性的角度被编程，是通过大量的重复和情绪，激活并连接了那些神经通路。所以我们可能，如果我们一直和照顾者在家在一起，而那是我们沉浸其中的主要环境，
very, like, tough and men don't cry and men get out in the field and do all the work. Like, if that is the environment you're raised in, even if you know it's incorrect, even if your parents know it's incorrect and have tried very hard to not enforce that within you, like it is still going to bleed in if it's kind of like the if it's kind of like what's in the air right if it's the thing that you breathe in if it's the thing that you see when you go to school when you hang out at your friend's place when you go to like the grocery store when you watch when you switch on TV like it's going to be reinforced or rewarded somehow how do you think that both are dismissive and a fearful avoidant attachment style separately obviously look different for different genders
那么我们更有可能看到这种情况。但我们还有所有其他特征和因素向我们袭来，对吧？就像，我们还有其他部分可以重新对我们进行编程，或者转移或改变我们。如果我们有很多——我这里只分享一个快速的例子：我曾有一位来访者，她是一位非常著名的体操运动员，她非常非常成功，赢得了好几次金牌。她有一个非常安全型的家庭，但她一直和教练在一起。她放学回家后不在家里呆任何时间，每晚去体操馆四五个小时，而她的教练让她变得极度焦虑型依恋。所以我们可能会有这些次要的影响，根据我们对它们的重复接触，实际上可以篡改我们最初的依恋风格线路。所以为了说明这一点，
Such a good question. So I would say if we break down each one, so dismissive avoidance as men and women, they both tend to share some unique characteristics, but men generally, it's a little bit more socially acceptable for men to be dismissive avoidance, similar to like what we're talking about on this concept. And so I think it's important to note that like your main first influences will be in the home because basically how we get programmed from a neuroplastic point of view, is like from neuroplasticity, we get programs formed through a lot of repetition and emotion, which fire and why are those neural pathways. And so we may have, if we're at home all the time with our caregivers, and that's the major environment we are being sort of immersed in,
这是一个非常好的问题。所以我认为如果我们把每一个都拆解开来，对于冷漠型回避依恋类型的男女来说，他们往往都有一些独特的特征，但总的来说，男性表现出冷漠型回避在社会上相对更容易被接受，这就类似于我们刚才讨论的这个概念。因此我认为重要的一点是，你要注意到你最初的主要影响来自于家庭，因为基本上我们从神经可塑性的角度被编程的方式，就像神经可塑性一样，我们的程序是通过大量的重复和情感形成的，这些重复和情感会激活并连接这些神经通路。所以如果我们整天都和照顾者待在家里，那是我们沉浸其中的主要环境，
then we're more likely to see that. But we have all these other features and factors coming at us, right? We're like, then we have these other parts that can either reprogram us or shift or change us. if we have a lot of like I'll share just one quick example here I had a um a client once and she was a a really well-known gymnast and she was very very successful she won a couple gold medals and um she had a very secure household but she was around coaches all the time she'd go home from school not spend any time at home go to the gym for four or five hours a night and her coach made her really anxiously attached so we can have these secondary influences that depending on our repeated exposure to them can actually usurp our original attachment style wiring. So just to speak to that for a second,
那么我们更有可能看到这种情况。但我们还有所有这些其他的特征和因素向我们袭来，对吧？就像是，我们还有其他一些部分，它们要么能重新为我们编程，要么能转变或改变我们。如果我们有很多像——我在这里分享一个简短的例子，我曾经有一个客户，她是一个非常著名的体操运动员，她非常非常成功，赢得过几枚金牌，而且她有一个非常稳固的家庭环境，但她总是和教练在一起。她放学后不回家，不在家待任何时间，而是每晚去体操馆四到五个小时，她的教练让她变得非常焦虑型依恋。所以我们可能会有这些次要的影响，根据我们对它们的重复接触程度，它们实际上可以取代我们最初的依恋风格布线。所以针对这一点多说一句，
I thought was so important, but dismissive avoidance as a whole, as a male, you'll tend to see that they present as very stoic, very unemotional, sometimes slow to warm up. They can be a lot of like the boys, boys, right? They tend to really like to spend time with other like-minded individuals. They get really into like their projects a lot of the time, their hobbies, those sorts of things. They tend to be logical, rational, practical, all of those different dynamics. We'll see those same things as a female dismissive avoidant. Like those traits really don't change that much. I would say more of what changes is society's response to those traits.
我觉得这非常重要，但从整体的逃避型回避来看，作为男性，你会发现他们表现得非常坚忍、极少流露情感，有时慢热。他们很像那种“哥们儿”，对吧？他们往往真的很喜欢和其他志同道合的人在一起。很多时候，他们会全身心投入到自己的项目、爱好以及诸如此类的事情中。他们往往讲逻辑、理性、务实，具备所有这些不同的动力。我们在女性逃避型回避身上也会看到同样的情况。这些特质其实并没有太大改变。我认为改变的更多是社会对这些特质的反应。
So men are sort of like they're okay to be that logical, rational, practical, withdrawn sort of person. Whereas with women, you know, sometimes it's like, well, why is she so standoffish? Or why is she not warm? Or why is she? And I think the external. response to it is more what changes, rather than anything else. And so I find that men kind of have an easier time and are more socially accepted as being a dismissive wooden compared to women.
所以男性的那种逻辑性、理性、务实、内向的形象是比较被接受的。而对于女性，你知道，有时人们会觉得，为什么她这么冷漠？或者为什么她不够热情？或者她为什么会这样？我认为外界对它的反应才是改变的关键，而不是其他什么。所以我发现，相比女性，男性在做逃避型回避时会更容易一些，也更能被社会所接受。
Again, overarching themes, not always the case, but we can definitely see that. And we'll sometimes see that dismissive wins are more likely to be kind of like the engineer types, right, to get really interested in that sort of style of learning. And they tend to really value their safety and their comfort zone. And they don't like to go and try tons of new things all the time. And again, that usually comes from childhood programming. So men and women share in a lot of those characteristics, but it's just the external response to it that seems to change. And from a fearful avoidant point of view,
同样，这些是总体趋势，并非总是如此，但我们确实能看到这一点。有时我们会发现逃避型更容易成为工程师类型的人，对吧，他们会对那种学习风格非常感兴趣。他们往往非常看重自己的安全感和舒适区。他们不喜欢总是去尝试大量的新事物。同样，这通常源于童年的编程。所以男女在许多这些特征上有共同点，但似乎只有外界的反应发生了变化。而从恐惧型回避的角度来看，
generally, fearful avoidant women will seem very warm and very, you know, kind and available until real attachment forms. And then they push away and they fear and those hot and cold patterns come about. And I find that that is kind of easier, if I had to say, between men and women, it's a little easier for women to be like that because they tend to be deep and they want to emotionally connect. with people and they care about like understanding human behavior and psychology whereas you know men that are fearful avoidant if they're big feelers if they really feel everything and then they're like
通常情况下，恐惧型回避的女性在真正的依恋形成之前，会显得非常热情、非常（你知道的）友善且随和。而一旦真正的依恋形成，她们就会推开对方、感到恐惧，这种忽冷忽热的模式就会出现。我发现，如果非要说男女之间有什么区别的话，这种状态对女性来说某种程度上更容易一些，因为她们往往情感深刻，渴望与人建立情感连接，并且关心人类行为和心理学的理解。而你知道，如果是恐惧型回避的男性，如果他们是情感丰富的人，如果他们真的能感受到一切，然后又表现得
hot and cold it's confusing for them right because they don't have as much support in their ability to emotionally process so those are some of the differences I would say like the traits and characteristics don't change much um but more how they then relate to a society based on their gender with their unique attachment styles. I feel like it just goes to show that we think that we're just socialized as children, but we are continually socialized as adults, right? And there continues to be these influences from our environment that can make us who we are and especially influence things like attachment style as well, which is a core component
忽冷忽热，这会让他们感到困惑，对吧？因为他们在情感处理能力方面没有得到那么多的支持。所以这些是我想说的一些区别，比如特质和特征没有太大改变，但更多的是他们如何根据自己的性别和独特的依恋风格与社会进行互动。我觉得这恰恰表明，我们以为自己只在童年时期被社会化，但我们在成年后也在不断地被社会化，对吧？来自环境的影响依然在继续塑造着我们，尤其会影响像依恋风格这样核心的要素，
of, I think becomes a more core component of our identity and how we relate to others, the older we get as we want to form those more serious long-term friendships and relationships and connections. I feel like recognizing this is one thing and it could probably feel quite overwhelming when you kind of finally wake up and smell the coffee or kind of begin to realize that this is not helping me anymore, that this is something that I needed to survive a childhood experience that I am now out of. I'm now separate from. And I do want to be able to connect and I do want to find meaningful, deep, secure love. How do we kind of approach healing when we get to that point of acceptance first? The next step is obviously to, obviously you can't rewrite history, but the next
随着我们年龄的增长，当我们想要建立更严肃的长期友谊、关系和连接时，依恋风格似乎成了我们身份以及我们如何与他人建立联系的更核心的组成部分。我觉意识到这一点是一回事，而当你终于大梦初醒，或者开始意识到“这不再对我有帮助了，这是我为了在已经远去的童年经历中生存下来而需要的东西，而我现在已经走出来了，我现在已经与之分离了”时，你可能会感到相当不知所措。我的确渴望能够去连接，我也确实想找到有意义、深厚、安全的爱。当我们到达这种首先接受的阶段时，我们该如何着手疗愈呢？接下来的步骤显然是，显然你无法重写历史，但下一步
step is to think about your future self and how you want to change for them. How are some of the ways that we go about, not undoing, but accepting and healing this part of us. Yeah, it's such a beautiful question. So we created a body of work and we had about 31,000 people go through our programs and take this information. And we see within about a 90 day period, we can change our attachment style. Now, that's the median of people, right? There's people who fall outside of that who may not be, you know, who may have way more
是去思考你未来的自己，以及你想为了他们做出怎样的改变。我们有哪些方法，不是去消除，而是去接受和疗愈我们身上的这一部分？是的，这是一个非常棒的问题。所以我们创造了一项研究成果，我们大约有31,000人完成了我们的项目并接受了这些信息。我们在大约90天的时间内看到我们可以改变我们的依恋风格。当然，这是人群的中位数，对吧？有些人不在此列，可能由于他们有更多的
childhood trauma and it may take them more than 90 days, but the vast majority of people can become dominantly securely attached in that. 90 day period and it's through focusing on a few crucial areas. So number one, and when we say like healing those parts of ourselves and accepting part of ourselves, I think it's we walk this really beautiful line between being able to be self-accepting, but also realize when there's a need for transformation, right? Like we can have a child who does something wrong at school, you know, break something or gets angry or throws a temper tantrum and it doesn't mean we like shame the child. we can be like, honey, I love you, I care about you, I want you to feel okay. And that's not acceptable
童年创伤，这可能需要他们花费超过90天的时间，但绝大多数人可以在那90天内转变为占主导地位的安全型依恋。这是通过专注于几个关键领域来实现的。所以第一点，当我们说“疗愈我们内心的那些部分”以及“接受我们的一部分”时，我觉得我们在维持一条非常美妙的界限：既能自我接纳，又能意识到何时需要转变，对吧？就像我们有一个孩子在学校做错了事，你知道，打破了什么东西，或者生气了，或者大发脾气，这并不意味着我们羞辱这个孩子。我们可以说：宝贝，我爱你，我关心你，我希望你觉得一切都好。
at the same time. Let's work on changing that behavior. So it's really like that attitude that we want to have to self-first, where we can be accepting of like, hey, this isn't my fault. I didn't choose my attachment style. It was whatever repeated things I got exposed to. And it is still my responsibility because only I can do that work. And so that work can look like going to counseling or therapy, but that work can also look like doing deep inner self-work. And so there's really a, few crucial areas that when we target these things, we can become securely attached. So crucial area number one is reprogramming core wounds. Our core wounds are like our relationship baggage. It's whatever we've been afflicted with as children, we will fear as adults. So if you
但与此同时，这种行为是不可接受的。让我们一起努力改变这种行为。所以这确实是我们首先对待自己的态度，我们可以接受：“嘿，这不是我的错。我没有选择我的依恋风格。这只是我不断接触到的重复事物所造成的。”同时这也依然是我的责任，因为只有我才能完成这项工作。所以这项工作可能看起来像是去寻求咨询或治疗，但也可能看起来像是进行深入的内心自我探索。因此确实有几个关键领域，当我们针对这些方面进行努力时，我们就能变得安全依恋。所以关键领域一，重塑核心创伤。我们的核心创伤就像我们的情感行李。我们在童年时受到过什么折磨，成年后就会恐惧什么。所以如果你
had a lot of broken trust as a child, you will as an adult be like, I will be betrayed and that's a core wound. Or if we had a lot of real or perceived abandonment in childhood, you know, through inconsistency or divorce or one parent pulls away, you will probably believe I will be abandoned as an adult. If you are criticized or neglected, you will believe I am defective and that's how people are going to see me. And so you can hear that in the different attachment cells, the fearful avoidance, the anxious, the dismissive avoidance. And so when we can first find our core wounds, we're not born with these things. We can just rewire them. And so we rewire them and I can always share a tool in a little bit, but we rewire them through repetition, emotion, and imagery.
在童年时经历了许多信任的破裂，你作为成年人就会觉得：“我会被背叛”，这就是一个核心创伤。或者，如果在童年中我们经历了许多真实的或感知的被抛弃，比如通过不一致、父母离异或其中一方疏离，你大概就会相信“我作为一个成年人会被抛弃”。如果你受到批评或忽视，你就会相信“我是有缺陷的”，而这就是别人看待你的方式。所以你可以在不同的依恋风格中听到这些，恐惧型回避、焦虑型、逃避型回避。因此，当我们能够首先找到我们的核心创伤时，我们并不是生来就有这些东西的。我们可以重塑它们。我们可以重塑它们——我稍后总是可以分享一个工具——但我们通过重复、情感和意象来重塑它们，
because that's what's necessary to recondition the subconscious mind. So there's a really easy tool to go through that. But number one area, core wounds. Number two, we learn our needs and how to meet them ourselves. So each attachment style is unique needs. Anxious tend to want a lot more certainty, consistency, validation, encouragement, to be made a priority, to feel important. Fearful avoidance want a lot of depth.
因为这是重新调节潜意识所必需的。所以有一个非常简单的工具可以经历这个过程。但第一大领域，核心创伤。第二大领域，我们了解自己的需求以及如何自己满足这些需求。每种依恋风格都有独特的需求。焦虑型往往想要更多的确定性、一致性、认可、鼓励，被当作首要任务，感到自己很重要。恐惧型回避想要很多深度。
They want novelty. They want growth in the relationship. They want deep connection, but they also want freedom and independence. and dismissable ones, they tend to actually respond very well to acceptance, support, empathy, and then small pieces of appreciation or acknowledgement, and then being able to also have their freedom and independence. So each attachment is different needs. When we learn to meet our own needs, and then number three, communicate them to other
他们想要新鲜感。他们想要关系中的成长。他们想要深度的连接，但他们同时也想要自由和独立。而逃避型回避，他们往往对接纳、支持、同理心反应很好，然后是少量的感激或认可，同时也能拥有他们的自由和独立。所以每种依恋都有不同的需求。当我们学会满足自己的需求，然后进行第三步，将它们传达给其他
people, that's like the framework for how we give and receive love. People talk about love languages, and that's great, and it's meaningful. but meeting each other's needs is much more impactful than the five love languages. And just as an example, like I have a big love language around quality time. But if I'm watching a movie on Netflix with somebody versus having a deep conversation, the deep conversation meets my need for emotional connection. That's going to be way more important to me than just quality time as an overarching theme, like deeply emotionally connecting with somebody's way better.
人，这就是我们如何付出和接受爱的框架。人们谈论爱的语言，这很好，也很有意义，但满足彼此的需求比五种爱的语言更具影响力。举个例子，我在“高质量陪伴”上有一种巨大的爱的语言。但如果我和某人在网飞上看电影，与进行一次深入的对话相比，深度的对话满足了我对情感连接的需求。这对我来说比单纯作为整体主题的高质量陪伴要重要得多，深入地与某人建立情感连接要好得多。
So our needs and learning what those are for each of our unique styles and meeting them for each other is like this huge set of ingredients and a roadmap to finding deeper connection and love. So core wounds, learning to meet our own needs, learning to communicate our needs to others, using healthy strategies. Sometimes we go, you never spend enough time with me instead of, hey, I miss you. I feel disconnected this week. I'd love to plan something fun on the weekend. That's called positive framing.
因此，我们的需求、了解我们每种独特风格的需求是什么、并为彼此满足这些需求，就像是一套庞大的成分表和通往更深层连接与爱的路线图。所以核心创伤、学会满足我们自己的需求、学会向他人表达我们的需求、使用健康的策略。有时我们会说“你从不花足够的时间陪我”，而不是说“嘿，我想你了。我觉得这周我们失去了连接。我很想在周末计划一些有趣的事情。”这被称为积极构建。
When we positively frame, we're more likely to get heard. So when we can be core wound reprogramers, meet our needs, learn to communicate better, and then learn healthier boundaries in our world. These are four of the most important components to becoming securely attached. When we can really target those, we can actually heal any maladaptive patterns that we were taught and we can leave the relationship baggage that we have from childhood in the past where it belongs. Oh my gosh, that is so, such like a perfect equation, I feel like.
当我们进行积极构建时，我们更有可能被倾听。因此，当我们能够成为核心创伤重塑者、满足我们的需求、学会更好地沟通，然后学会在我们的世界中建立更健康的边界时，这些就是成为安全依恋最重要的四个组成部分。当我们真正专注于这些时，我们实际上可以疗愈我们被教导的所有适应不良的模式，并且我们可以把童年留下的情感行李留在属于它的过去。天哪，我觉得这真是一个完美的公式。
And I love that you've spoke about needs instead of love language. I will say I think love languages are like an amazing idea, but there is not as much research on them as you would probably like for such a huge term used in psychobabble. And something they say is that it's not really a complete picture of what we need as people and as emotional beings. You know, five love languages does not make a relationship, does not make a human. Like there is a deeper core need behind each of them that can be met not just through
我很高兴你谈论的是需求而不是爱的语言。我要说的是，我认为爱的语言是一个绝妙的主意，但对于这样一个在心理学大杂烩中被广泛使用的巨大术语来说，并没有像你所希望的那样多的研究。他们所说的一点是，它并不是我们作为人和情感存在所需内容的完整写照。你知道，五种爱的语言并不能构成一段关系，也不能构成一个人。就像它们背后都有一个更深层的核心需求，而这个需求不仅可以通过
that expression that we normally talk about. Do you think that it's easier to heal? I'm going to ask you one final question. It's another hot seat question. So yes, I'm sure you have an amazing answer. But do you think that it's easier to heal and avoid an attachment style, dismissive, or fearful when you are single or in a relationship? Oh my gosh.
我们通常谈论的那种表达。你觉得疗愈会更容易吗？我要问你最后一个问题。这也是一个“热点”问题。所以是的，我确信你会有个精彩的回答。但你认为，当你单身或处于恋爱关系中时，疗愈并避免依恋风格（无论是疏离型还是恐惧型）会更容易吗？噢天哪。
What a great question. So I will say it depends on a number of factors. So we get this question all the time in our programs. People will constantly ask me this in like the weekly webinars we do. And I would say that it depends on how codependent you are. The reason being that if we are in a relationship and we're highly codependent, so usually this means if you're anxiously attached or even fearful avoided, we tend to have a lot of those more codependent patterns where we'll kind of people please
多棒的问题啊。那我先说，这取决于很多因素。我们在节目中经常遇到这个问题。大家在我们每周举办的网络研讨会上总是会问我这个问题。我想说，这取决于你的共情依赖（codependent）程度有多高。原因在于，如果我们处于恋爱关系中，并且共情依赖度很高，通常这意味着如果你是焦虑型依恋，甚至是恐惧疏离型，我们往往会有很多更严重的共情依赖模式，比如我们会迎合他人
or put other people before ourselves. And because people wouldn't share in that anxious side, it's quite a likelihood towards codependency. So if we are more codependent and we're trying to heal our attachment style while in a relationship, sometimes it's hard because we will get really locked into prioritizing the relationship over our own self-work. But if you're somebody who's highly committed to your personal growth and it's like a huge passion and you can really trust yourself to be mindful of that, then the reality is we can see faster progress in a relationship as well because that's the real life work, right? That's like where we're really going to do
或者把别人排在自己前面。正因为人们不会分享那种焦虑的一面，这非常容易导致共情依赖。因此，如果我们共情依赖更严重，却试图在恋爱关系中疗愈自己的依恋风格，有时会很困难，因为我们会过于执着于将关系置于自我成长之上。但如果你是一个高度致力于个人成长、将其视为巨大热情并且能够真正信任自己去注意这一点的人，那么现实是，我们也可以在恋爱关系中看到更快的进展，因为那是真实的现实生活工作，对吧？那是我们将真正付诸
that work and have to communicate differently and have to reprogram our core wounds so we don't take things personally and have to like actually share our needs with somebody so we can have really profound results in a short period of time if we're highly committed if we're not that committed and we're just kind of dabbling around and like oh you know i'm kind of i read about personal growth once a month or something like that then it's going to be easier to stay committed when we don't have the distraction of codependency by being more anxious leaning in our attachment style um dismissive avoidance tend to actually do really well at healing when in a relationship because they're more action oriented. So they tend to do better when they're actually like showing up if they're committed to doing so.
实践并必须进行不同沟通的地方，我们必须重塑核心创伤，这样我们才不会把事情放在心上，还必须真正与某人分享我们的需求，因此，如果我们高度投入，我们可以在短时间内取得非常深远的结果；如果我们投入度不高，只是随便涉猎，比如“哦，你知道的，我大概一个月读一次关于个人成长的书”之类的，那么当我们没有共情依赖的干扰时，保持投入就会更容易。通过在依恋风格上更倾向于焦虑，嗯，疏离回避型的人在恋爱关系中实际上往往在疗愈方面做得很好，因为他们更注重行动。因此，如果他们承诺这样做，他们往往会在实际表现出来时做得更好。
And so I would say overall you'll generally see that easiest to hardest to heal. I would say anxious and dismissives generally heal a little quicker because they have less attachment trauma. Fearful avoidance generally have a little bit more. Although when you get them into personal growth related stuff, they tend to like go a million miles an hour and really get stuck into the work. Um, because they tend to really like the depth of all of that stuff. Those are those fearful avoidant needs and they like growth.
所以我想说，总体而言，你会发现从最容易到最难的疗愈顺序。我想说焦虑型和疏离型通常恢复得更快，因为他们的依恋创伤较少。恐惧疏离型的创伤通常要多一些。不过，当你让他们参与个人成长相关的事情时，他们往往会以百万英里每小时的速度前进，真正投入到工作中。嗯，因为他们往往真的很喜欢所有这些东西的深度。这些就是那些恐惧疏离者的需求，他们喜欢成长。
Um, but we will see that as long as somebody is highly committed in or out of a relationship can work. I personally, when I first started doing a lot of healing work was really single for like three and a half years. I was like, I'm not dating anybody, anything.
嗯，不过我们会发现，只要一个人高度投入，无论是在恋爱中还是单身，都是可行的。我个人刚开始做大量疗愈工作时，单身了大约三年半。我当时想：“我谁也不约会，什么都不做。”
And I was really codependent and I think that was good for me. But in re, in retrospect, respect, like, I didn't need three and a half years. Like, I could have, you know, done the first year or two of work that I did and then gotten back into relationship. And I had a lot of work to do. But you'll see if people are committed, that's really the overarching factor, whether you're in or out of the relationship. Are you doing the work? Are you willing to stay consistent with it? And as long as you're doing that, I think that you can actually have more of an upside on being in a relationship because it can create more rapid growth more quickly. That is such an amazing.
我当时共情依赖很重，我觉得这对我有好处。但在回顾过去时，其实，我并不需要三年半。比如，我可以完成我所做的前一两年工作，然后就回到恋爱关系中。我有很多工作要做。但你会发现，如果人们有决心，这才是最重要的决定性因素，无论你是在恋爱中还是单身。你在做这项工作吗？你愿意保持一致性吗？只要你这样做，我认为在恋爱关系中其实会有更多优势，因为它可以更快地创造更显著的成长。这真是一个令人惊叹的
answer and I love how there's like it's not just a simple one you know it's not just like no yeah you should be single before you fix this you know you need to be single in order to work through this it's like no there are a lot of people who are in relationships that have been quite successful but they just want them to be better and they just realize that maybe this won't this won't last if this underlying pattern is not addressed so that's kind of all the questions I have for you today thank you so much for coming on the show and breaking this down And is there anything else on avoidant attachment stars on theory that you haven't mentioned that you want to quickly say something about? I'll say one last really quick thing, which is that I find it to also be really powerful
回答，我非常喜欢这种答案并不是非黑即白的，你知道的，它不仅仅是“不，是的，你在解决这个问题之前应该单身”，你知道的，“你需要单身才能解决这个问题”，而是“不，有很多人在恋爱关系中非常成功，但他们只是希望关系变得更好，他们只是意识到，如果不解决潜在的模式，这种关系可能不会长久”。这就是我今天要问你的所有问题了，非常感谢你来到节目中并做这么深入的剖析。关于疏离型依恋风格或理论，还有什么你没提到但想快速补充的吗？我最后简单补充一点，那就是我发现它同样非常强大
as an accompanying healing strategy that we do a little bit of nervous system regulation work. So if anybody is on this journey and they can just apply a simple tool like meditating in the morning or breathwork in the evenings or just something that's helping them get out of this constant fight or flight and just get more back into their body and present in the relationship to self. It's usually like the fifth major pillar. I'll mention after the core wounds and the needs and the boundaries and communication as this kind of honorable mention that can just fast track the healing process. So another really great thing to focus on for sure. Yeah, it's honestly amazing because I feel like when you're, I don't know, reconstructing how you see love and how you see
作为一种辅助的疗愈策略，我们可以做一点神经系统调节工作。因此，如果任何人正走在这个旅程中，并且可以应用一个简单的工具，比如早晨冥想、晚上呼吸练习，或者只是能帮助他们摆脱这种持续的“战斗或逃跑”状态、更多地回到自己的身体并存在于与自我的关系中的某种方法。这通常就像第五大支柱。我会在核心创伤、需求、边界和沟通之后提到这一点，作为这样一个荣誉提名，它可以让疗愈过程快车道化。所以这绝对是另一个非常值得关注的伟大之处。是的，这真的很了不起，因为我觉得当你，我不知道，在重建你如何看待爱以及你如何看待
others and how you see connection, like it's going to be pretty scary and there will definitely be moments of like distress and moments of perhaps panic and being able to slow down and say to yourself, this is just an emotion, this is just a feeling, this is nothing that's going to end my life, nothing that's going to ruin my life. It's just my nervous system doing what it's meant to do, which is respond to a perceived threat. Yeah, I feel like we're going to be so much more successful. So thank you again for coming on, a reminder that Taise had another episode with us back in December, I think, on Anxious Attachment Stars if you want to go and listen to that one as well. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Google Podcasts, I don't know, wherever you're listening and make sure that you're following along. It really does help the show to grow and to reach new people who might need to.
他人以及你如何看待连接时，这会相当可怕，而且绝对会有痛苦的时刻和可能的恐慌时刻，能够慢下来并对自己说：“这只是一种情绪，这只是一种感觉，这不会结束我的生活，不会毁了我的生活。这只是我的神经系统在做它该做的事，也就是对感知到的威胁做出反应。”是的，我觉得我们会取得更大的成功。所以再次感谢你的到来，提醒大家泰斯（Taise）在去年12月左右曾和我们有过另一期节目，我想是关于焦虑型依恋风格的，如果你想去听听那一期的话。一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify、谷歌播客上给我们留下五星评价，我不知道，无论你在哪里听，都要确保关注我们。这确实有助于节目的成长，并接触到可能需要听到这些内容的新人。
to hear some of the things that we're talking about. If you have an episode suggestion, if you have a contribution to this episode, something that we didn't talk about, something that you would want us to expand on further, your own experience, please message me at that psychology podcast. I would love to hear from you.
听到我们正在谈论的一些事情。如果你有节目建议，如果你对这期节目有什么补充，有什么我们没有谈到的、你希望我们进一步展开的内容，或者你自己的经历，请在That Psychology Podcast上给我发消息。我很希望能听到你的声音。
And as always, until we speak next, stay kind, be safe and be gentle with yourself. We will be back next week. On the Look Back at a podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
一如既往，直到我们下次交谈，保持善良，注意安全，对自己温柔一点。我们下周将回到《回看播客》（Look Back At Podcast）。对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我的意思是，那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的黑人年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看播客》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？正在收听《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way），由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方真的都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHard Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens. finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着季度的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这是当也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。